i was 20 i worked for the sanitation
department i was a garbage man you were
a garbage i was a garbage man i worked
the back of the truck
22 square blocks that's hard doing
movies there's nothing that we do in the
movies
so never give up
without commitment
you'll never start but more importantly
without consistency
you'll never finish
it's not easy
if it were easy there'd be no denzel
washington so
keep working
keep striving never give up fall down
seven times get up eight
ease
is a greater threat to progress
than hardship
so keep moving keep growing keep
learning
what my mother said to me was denzel you
do a lot of good
but you must do good the right way can't
buy your way in
can't love your way in
you got to serve you got to do good the
right way so at 66 getting ready to be
67 having just buried my mother
i made a promise to her and to god not
just to do good the right way but to
honor my mother and my father by the way
i live my life the rest of my days on
this earth i'm here to serve
to help
to provide
small minds
discuss other people good minds discuss
events great minds discuss ideas
in this
twitter tweet meme
mean world that we've created for our
children the least we can do is consider
what we've done and think about the
young people the future and individually
collectively do the best we can to try
and turn this thing around i blame no
one i look in the mirror
on the other side of it what an
opportunity we have
because tomorrow's the first day of the
rest of our lives
the most selfish thing i've done in my
life
is give
because of the joy
that i get from it i love it
i don't like it i love it
i couldn't have done it on my mother i
couldn't have done it without my wife i
couldn't have done it without my
children who teaches you to be a man
stay on your knees
watch me but listen to god don't listen
to me i hope that the words of my mouth
and the meditation of my heart are
pleasing in god's sight but they're i'm
human i'm just like you what i have will
not keep me on this earth for one more
day
i never looked at things as problems i
look at them as opportunities don't just
aspire to make a living aspire to make a
difference
goals
on the road to achievement
cannot be achieved without
discipline and consistency don't confuse
movement with progress because you can
run in place and not get anything done
so are you moving forward and who you
taking with you
you will fail at some point in your life
accept it you will lose you will
embarrass yourself you will suck at
something there's no doubt about it i'm
telling you embrace it because it's
inevitable and i should know in the
acting business you fail all the time
early on in my career i auditioned for a
part in the broadway music perfect role
for me i thought
except for the fact that i can't sing so
i didn't get the job but here's the
thing i didn't quit i didn't fall back i
walked out of there to prepare for the
next audition and the next audition and
the next audition i prayed and i prayed
but i continued to fail
and fail
and fail but it didn't matter because
you know what
there's an old saying
you hang around the barber shop long
enough sooner or later you're going to
get a haircut so you will catch a break
and i did catch a break
i found that nothing in life
is worthwhile
unless you take risks
nothing
nelson mandela said there is no passion
to be found
playing small
in settling for a life that's less
than the one you're capable of living
now i'm sure in your experiences in
school and applying to college and
picking your major and deciding what you
want to do with life i'm sure people
have told you to make sure you have
something to fall back on make sure you
got something to fall back on honey but
i never understood that concept having
something to fall back on
if i'm going to fall
i don't want to fall back on anything
except my faith i want to fall forward i
figure at least this way i'll see what
i'm going to hit
fall forward
fail
big
today's the beginning of the rest of
your life and it can be it's going to be
very frightening it's a new world out
there it's a mean world out there and
you only live once so do what you feel
passionate about take chances
professionally so don't be afraid to go
outside the box
don't be afraid to
think outside the box don't be afraid to
fail
big
to dream
big but remember
dreams
without goals
are just dreams
and they ultimately fuel disappointment
so have dreams but have goals life goals
yearly goals
monthly goals daily goals and understand
that to achieve these goals you must
apply discipline and consistency in
order to achieve your goals you must
apply discipline which you've already
done and consistency every day not just
on tuesday and miss a few days you have
to work at it every day you have to plan
every day you've heard the saying we
don't plan to fail we failed to plan
hard work
works working really hard
is what successful people do
remember that just because you're doing
a lot more doesn't mean you're getting a
lot more
done don't confuse
movement
with progress then one of the most
important lessons in life
that you should know is to remember to
have an attitude of gratitude of
humility understand where the gift comes
from it's not mine it's been given to me
by the grace of god on your last day you
can't take it with me but you can leave
it here if you don't fail you're not
even trying my wife told me this great
expression to get something you never
had you have to do something you never
did
imagine you're on your deathbed and
standing around your deathbed are the
ghosts representing your unfulfilled
potential the ghost of the ideas you
never acted on the ghost of the talents
you didn't use and they're standing
around your bed angry disappointed and
upset
they say we we came to you because you
could have brought us to life they say
and now we have to go to the grave
together so i ask you today
how many ghosts are going to be around
your bed when your time comes
reggie jackson struck out 2600 times in
his career the most
in the history of baseball but you don't
hear about the strikeouts people
remember the home runs
fall forward
thomas edison conducted one thousand
failed experiments did you know that i
didn't know that
because the one thousand and first was
the light bulb fall forward
every failed experiment is one step
closer to success you've got to take
risks so continue to strive continue to
have goals continue to
progress
never be discouraged
never hold back give everything you got
and when you fall throughout life and
maybe even tonight after a few mini
glasses of champagne remember this
fall forward
[Music]